good morning thank you all for coming
today for what I think you're going to
enjoy very much my name is Josh wheeler
I'm the director of the Thomas Jefferson
Center for the protection of free
expression we are the hosts of this
program today it's a source of great
pride for us at the center that this is
the 22nd Virginia festival of the book
and the center has been involved in one
way or another with all 22 festivals and
it's something that we hope to continue
to do for many years to come because I
think one of the best ways to combat
censorship are the desire to censor
speech we don't like is to remind people
of the many benefits that we receive
from free speech and by having this kind
of festival celebrating the right of
free speech is I think a way to remind
folks well it's it's a small price to
pay when sometimes we have to hear cups
some things that we might not want to
hear for all the benefits of being able
to explore any idea any theme and any
concept without any fear of government
reprises so there we go
she knows this applause for the First
Amendment now I know that the 22 years
it was actually in this very room that I
discovered that I needed to wear glasses
because at some point I don't know it
was three or four festivals in I found
myself doing this number of you know
they asked me to read some housekeeping
details at the beginning and so I
brought this up and then so you'll have
to ask me be patient with me with my
glasses on but I do want to to tell you
that this is the Virginia festival of
the book obviously which is the product
of the Virginia Foundation for the
Humanities I've been asked to ask
everybody in the audience to please
silence their cell phones not just for
us but this is going to be recorded and
if you would like to tweet about this
event
you can do so at hashtag VA book 2016
and I say that as if I have any idea
what it means and if you're gonna tweet
about this event include me I am at
Kelly underscore Carlin please she could
be speaking a foreign language right now
I have no idea actually I know a little
bit about that Kelly is actually a very
proficient tweeter with quite a how many
followers you have now almost 30,000 Wow
so supporting the festival the festival
is free of charge not free of cost
please remember to go online and give
back or pick up a giving envelope from
the information desk at the Omni and
support your festivals so we may sustain
it for many more years to come
evaluations please fill out program
evaluations these provide useful
information that helped keep the
festival free and open to the public you
can fill out a paper evaluation before
you leave or complete it online at VA
button org slash survey I do know what
that means after this event after at the
end of this program we are going to have
books available for sale right down here
and I think we could prevail upon our
guest our author to sign a copy if you'd
like I think that'll be okay we are here
today to talk about this book a Carlin
Home Companion growing up with George
and we will talk a little bit about
about that in the future as I said the
center has been involved in many of
these programs in the past and I've had
the great pleasure to moderate them a
number of them I realized though
probably about the third or fourth time
that people weren't here to hear me they
were actually more interested in hearing
about the book or the author and so I
have learned that the best questions
actually come from the audience itself
so I am going to very early on stop
asking the questions and make the the
the envelope of the envelope the
microphone available to you folks
we'll bring the microphone around to
anybody who has a question I told Kelly
that I can I can ask questions if this
audience doesn't have any but I have
never found that to be a problem with
Charlottesville audience and I can blah
blah blah for anyone but let me tell you
a little bit about our author today
Kelly Carlin has written for film TV and
most recently the stage her critically
acclaimed solo show a Carlin Home
Companion her master's degree in
counseling psychology from Pacifica
Graduate Institute informs her work as
an author speaker workshop leader and
citizen of Earth she lives in Los
Angeles with her husband Bob McCall and
their Jack Russell Terrier Stella but
dreams of living somewhere with a lot
fewer cars someday long as you avoid 29
north
I think Charlotte's Ville will you
please join me in welcoming Kelly Carlin
I should also say very very proud of the
fact that Kelly Carlin is on the Thomas
Jefferson centers Board of Trustees a
strong believer in free speech yes and
we're thrilled to have her to help
direct the center's efforts but first
question yes what compelled you to write
your book
well it's interesting I've been wanting
to write and tell my story for about 15
well now that would be 17 years it's
funny how that does the time thing does
that like that my mom died in 97 and
after she died pretty suddenly pretty
quickly diagnosed with liver cancer was
dead five weeks later pretty shocking a
huge wake-up call for me as a human as
an artist is all sorts of things and I'd
had this wild and crazy life I was 34 35
at that time and I'd already had I felt
like I already had lived seven lives and
I I wanted to tell my story my survivor
story because at 35 I was a very
different person than I was at 25 or at
20 or at 15 or at 10 I mean there's just
so many different iterations of my life
with my family and then my life as an
adult or what I was pretending to be an
adult at least and so I wanted to tell
my survivors story and I knew that yeah
okay so it's a little hook they're a
little interesting I happened to be
George Carlin's daughter and yes part of
my story is quite fun with my dad and my
mom in the 60s and the 70s and in the
80s and all the way through it it might
tell my dad's death but I had you know
my parents had drug and alcohol issues
when I was a child until I was 12 my
mother was an alcoholic she almost died
she got sober there was a lot of money
and cocaine and fame in my house and all
the weird stuff that comes along
with that some great stories around that
which maybe we'll share today and so I
I'd lived through that we our family had
lived through that my father's heart
disease my mother's breast cancer I'd
gotten involved in some abusive
relationships my own drug addiction
panic attack syndrome I'd been through a
lot of stuff and I felt like because I
had gotten through it and found a way to
get my feet back on the ground and find
my Center finally that I really wanted
to share that with the world I wanted to
I don't know pay it forward in some way
I was such so lucky to be grow up in the
family that I grew up even though it was
pretty chaotic for quite a few years but
I understood my privilege and so I
wanted to share that I wanted to
experience strength and hope and that's
part of the reason why I wanted to write
the book now that I've written it and
I've been sitting with it and kind of
looking back on it and talking a lot
about it the last five or six months I
also see that being an only child
growing up in the shadow of Fame growing
up in a family where the adults chaos
was in charge of my life until I was 12
years old I didn't feel like I had a
real voice or a place in the world and I
see now that telling my story is a way
for me to to heal that ultimately to say
I exist I'm here I matter like we all do
every single one of us has a story to
tell and and and so I can see that it's
on some level that there's that that
issue it that's one of the themes in the
book invisibility visibility is is one
of the themes I talk about and I see now
that um that that's part of it too is
just was something about being seen and
heard which all children want ultimately
so so here I am being seen and heard
big-time I want this program to be very
much about about your book because it's
a fascinating book as you say survivors
tale and but a big part of that of
course is
your parents yes and and you're a writer
you've written for stage for screen for
publication yes and and I can only
assume that you inherited that in some
part from your father who loved who
loved the written word actually heard it
inherited from the Carlin family itself
well that's what I was gonna ask is is
was did that start with your father or
there's a great story in the book about
perhaps where he he got his Louisville
yeah I know where that story is but but
um
Carlin family were Irish gift of the gab
and all that stuff my dad's father
Patrick Carlin my dad didn't really know
his father his father couldn't
metabolize ethanol very well as my
father used to say and when he wasn't
drinking he was a brilliant man he was a
big advertising guy in New York City
sold advertising for all the big papers
like national level salesman brilliant
salesman and also one speaking contests
you know Dale Carnegie and stuff like
that national speaking awards had a real
gift for it my dad never knew him though
because his mother my dad's mother Mary
when my dad was about three months old
took my father and his older brother
Patrick and snuck down the fire escape
because she was tired of being battered
around by Patrick senior and Patrick
senior had started battering around
young Patrick too and she wanted to
protect my father from that so there was
the gift of the gab from that and then
Mary was an amazing storyteller she was
someone who would take a bus ride
downtown and back uptown and have a full
story about who was on the bus beginning
middle and end punchline the whole thing
really a very funny witty woman and
there's a little story here of my dad
here I'll just read a little bit of this
on May 12th 1937 George Denis Patrick
Carlin was born eight weeks later after
months of trying to make the marriage
work
Mary sneaked out the fire escape in the
middle of the night with her two young
boys leaving Patrick Carlin senior and
his rage for good she'd seen the damage
that her husband had already done to
little Patrick and she was not going to
let sweet George be another victim this
time it's stuck she tried to leave him a
few times before
even though Patrick tried to woo her
back she held strong George never saw
his dad again in 1945 his father died of
a massive heart attack at the age of 57
my dad was eight years old without a man
around to keep my dad out of trouble on
the streets of the Upper West Side of
Manhattan or what he and his friends
like to call Irish Harlem Mary took her
job as both mother and father very
seriously she looked for ways to shape
and control young George's mind in life
she succeeded in only one area a love of
language and words Mary ocher Mary
encouraged my dad to look up words he
didn't know in the dictionary and then
use them in conversation one morning
young George wanting to show off a new
word he had learned excitedly asked his
mother if she had perused the paper that
morning he anticipated her approval
slowly she turned sharpened her gaze
onto him and said I have not actually
I've only given it a cursory glance
George chagrined turned around and
marched right back to the dictionary to
learn the new word cursory that was Mary
Carlin in a nutshell loved to be the
have the upper hand in every situation
but she did she encouraged my dad my
dad's love of language big time and my
dad encouraged me too with a love of
language he used to do this thing well
into my 30s too I might add which was
very irritating if I was with him and
having we were with people or whatever
in conversation and I would pronounce a
word wrong he would slip me a piece of
paper later with the correct
pronunciation like written out like it
does in the dictionary you know and I
would just I mean I get it dad was
trying to protect me and make sure I
sounded smart and everything like that
but into your 30s at some point you're
like dad I'm just feeling a little I'm
not so great about that
I'd love to just read a little bit of
the beginning here of my book to just to
jump back a little bit because there's
something about my life that I don't
know has always felt faded in some way
and I just want to read a little to you
a little bit about about that
Carlin legend holds that all it took for
me to come into the world was a little
sperm a little egg a little Scotch a
little weed and something called the
limbo we've been trying to get pregnant
for months but no luck explained my mom
to me seven-year old Kelly as I sat on
the bed watching my dad pack for the
road just moments earlier he said to me
when I'm down in New Orleans I'll get a
postcard from the hotel you were
conceived in and send it to you confused
by the word conceived I looked at my mom
and she quickly filled in the details
well you see we were down in New Orleans
must have been what October 62 we were
at a club hanging out with some
musicians we'd met when someone
announced a limbo contest well it
sounded like fun and so I did it
next thing I knew I was
pregnant mom didn't mention the weed or
Scotch
in her telling of my fateful beginning
because she didn't need to they were a
given no sorry about that
they were a given dad had been smoking
weed and drinking beers since he was 14
and mom started sneaking sips off her
daddy's drinks at around the same age
and as far as the limbo goes I'm still
not clear about the mechanics of it all
but that's never mattered it clearly
worked I am here for the two years
leading up to the night of the limbo my
mom Brenda and my dad George had been
constant companions starving artists and
comrades in arms chasing my dad's comedy
dreams they did hell gigs packed and
unpacked their suitcases hundreds of
times and traveled to almost every state
in the country in their 57 Dodge Dart
my mom loved playing the role of on the
road partner-in-crime - my dad's rebel
artist on a mission she was dad's lover
party girl and press agent all rolled
into one his full partner in life and
always his best audience you could
always hear her great laugh above the
din of clinking glasses and mumbling
patrons in every club they visited
because dad was a complete unknown on
some nights she was the only person in
the audience one night in Baltimore
no one was in the audience not even my
mom my dad asked the club owner um so
exactly why am I going on cuz you know
with people come in I want them to know
we got some entertainment
I hear dad killed that night
during those lean years dad paid his
dues but also got lucky
one night Lenny Bruce caught his act in
Chicago loved what he saw and introduced
him to his manager Murray Becker this
was huge
my dad worshipped Lenny taking every
opportunity to soak up Lenny's presence
my mom and dad would drive from New York
to the gate of horn Club in Chicago just
to see him perform one night while they
were there Lenny got arrested halfway
through his set this had become the norm
that night the cops did not like the use
of his word I'll not say that because
we're doing TV here it's a very
descriptive word looking to hassle the
club the cops began to ask everyone for
their IDs when they got to my dad he
defiantly told them yeah I don't believe
in identification and the cops promptly
threw him into the back of the paddy
wagon with Lenny when my dad proudly
told Lenny what he had done Lenny looked
at him and said what are you a schmuck
my mom chased that paddy wagon by foot
all the way to the police station that
night and bailed them out of jail
growing up surrounded by stories like
these and living through many others
myself I've always felt as if my
family's journey has unfolded like some
kind of mythological legend our lives
together have felt shaped by a force
threads of fate or maybe even what my
dad called the big electron something
was calling us forth and interweaving
exactly the right people places and
things to form one amazing life together
it's just always seemed so destined so
maybe we should talk a little bit about
the First Amendment I do want to do we
can talk about that now or we could I
also want to talk about sort of the next
phase after your conception ah one of
the things I love about Ed was so I
definitely will talk about First
Amendment particularly how we met I want
to share that anecdote but one of the
things I really love
about your book is you I think you did
you spend some time in the titles or the
chapter yes sure and one of the I think
really enlightening ones in terms of
your youth
is the the three musketeers the chapter
titled the three musketeers and the sort
of that part of your life yeah and I
thought if you could share a little sure
absolutely so because I was an only
child there were only three of us and
early on at some point my dad began
calling us the three musketeers all for
one one for all and and that became a
real theme well I mean you know when
you're an only child and any of a
tight-knit family like that you feel
like it's sometimes like the three of
you just kind of against the you and you
against the world kind of a thing and it
felt like that sometimes certainly in
our lives especially in the 70s when my
dad was considered a hippie freak and it
felt like the whole world was against us
on some level but this also became a
theme in our life in a sense that you
know if you grow up in a dysfunctional
family and I'm sure none of you here
haven't understand what I'm talking
about there's a sense of loyalty to your
family that happens and there's a
willingness to keep your family secrets
for your family to keep them protected
to because you love them because it's
the right thing to do in the moment
because you want to protect your
family's reputation and you don't want
to tell strangers what's going on at
your house and so there's there there's
a sense of that in my family of you know
when you when you grow up and there was
some crazy stuff going on in our
household and I'm just looking here for
a little bit of this this this sense of
the three musketeers you know it was a
great sense of belonging in that way and
yet it also kept our alcoholic family
secrets
and I don't think helped us in a lot in
the long run a lot of crazy stuff went
on in my house
around that and but it there's a warmth
to it that I do I do love and adore and
actually I was I went to my that my book
launch the Barnes & Noble in LA someone
came to me and gave me a little Hot
Wheels car that had the three musketeers
on it little Three Musketeers got and I
just I just it's on my it's on my like
in my little alter I just so coveted so
much but I'd like to give a little
reader here a little bit about kind of
what uh Scarlet of what we carlins were
doing in in the the summer of 1972 to
give you an idea of how important it was
to be the three musketeers in the summer
of 1972 mom and I went on the road with
dad the road was always a fun adventure
some of my earliest memories from the
road are waking up in a hotel room with
both my parents dead to the world and
spending the next few hours coloring
watching cartoons with the volume all
the way down and staring out the window
at the city below finally when I was
starving I'd nudge my parents awake dad
would run down to a local diner or store
or as he got more successful order room
service and buy a bunch of those mini
boxes of rice krispies and a quart of
milk he then carefully take out his
pocket knife cut open those teeny boxes
and magically transformed them into an
instant bowl abra cadabra breakfast was
served and although I'd never heard it
I'm absolutely sure that it was one of
those morning's that my dad heard that
famous snap crackle you our first stop
that summer was Kent State my dad took
me to the memorial for the four college
kids that had been shot by the National
Guard a few years before he explained
that they'd been protesting against the
war standing up for what they believed
in and that the government had silenced
them by shooting them this was one of
those daddy's big teaching moments he
wanted me to understand the importance
of people
standing up for what they believed in
especially those who were willing to
stand up for their government to make
their point he explained how the
government had always silenced those who
did not have a voice to begin with
blacks and Native Americans especially
and how young white American girls and
boys were now in that category too I
felt there was no safe place for anyone
being a nine year old only child and one
who felt an increasing need to be more
mature than my years I acted as calm and
cool and collected as I could I tried to
show my dad that I understood the
lessons of civics and morality that he
was trying to teach me but it was just a
calm manner because all I could think
was if the government was shooting these
people for standing up for what they
believed in would they shoot mean or
even my dad it was a terrifying thought
that now echoed in the back of my mind
the next stop on our summer of 72 tour
was Summerfest in Milwaukee Summerfest
is basically an ocean of beer
surrounding an island of sausage you
know what they call good clean American
fun and you know when I think good clean
American fun don't you also immediately
think George Carlin dad opened for arlo
guthrie and struggled to do his new
material while connecting with the
enormous audience of over 10,000 people
he began to do his new routine the seven
words you can never say on television
which he just recorded on his third
album class clown the album wouldn't be
released for another few months so I'm
pretty sure the promoter didn't know
exactly what he had signed up for when
he booked my dad the routine was both
hilarious and an intellectual
examination of the usage of language in
our culture however it consisted of
words according to my dad quote that'll
infect your soul curve your spine and
keep the country from winning the war
and the seven dirty words are you know
what they are you want to say them
[ __ ] the book [ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and tits some
poor woman outside of Charlottesville
watching this live just had a stroke I
apologize to her family now okay good
yes she has yes those words because
Summerfest was an outdoor venue the
mainstage Act could be heard throughout
the fairgrounds meaning it could be
heard by lots of mommies and daddies and
little kiddies so there was my dad on
stage killing most of the audience was
loving it while mom and I stood in the
wings also enjoying the show that's when
the promoter rushed up to my mom and
said look the cops are here they're
complaining about the language and
they're going to arrest George the
minute he gets off stage I guess when my
dad said that he'd like to everyone in
the audience the nice Midwestern
policeman took some offense at that
knowing that he was carrying drugs in
his pockets
both grass and coke my mom knew that she
had to think fast she grabbed a glass of
water and walked out onto the stage dad
was very confused but took the water and
mom whispered to him exit stage left
the cops are here dad wrapped it up
exited stage left and we all quickly
hustled into the dressing room and
locked the door I anxiously watched as
mom removed a rather large baggie of
cocaine from her purse and stashed it in
a bass drum and dad took out the joint
and small vial of coke from his pockets
and handed them to the promoter the
promoter was trying to keep things calm
when suddenly there was a bang it
sounded as if a gun had gone off I left
into my mother's arms and began crying
hysterically as she tried to calm me
down
nothing else happened someone said it
was probably just a balloon someone had
popped a balloon mom dad and the
promoter all laughed a nervous laugh
but I was now on him
terror streaked through my body I
couldn't breathe I felt like I was going
to die
and that's when the door opened my dad
walked out and within a few seconds
policemen cuffed him
I screamed daddy I was sure that I would
never ever see him again mom held me
back as I cried I don't know how long it
took but she finally calmed me down
enough so that she could leave to get my
dad out of jail luckily my mom knew
exactly what to do because of Lenny
Bruce's arrest in Chicago in 1961 you
get a civil rights attorney I went home
with the promoter to his house and
family where I spent the rest of the
weekend distracting myself by swimming
with kids in something that as a
Southern California girl I had never
seen before an above-ground pool I
almost didn't know what to do with it
I'm just thinking of the irony of when
this show gets broadcast about seven
words you can't say on television and
and it the irony of course is the Thomas
Jefferson Center for the protection of
free expression sponsoring a program
yeah and then the seven dirty words are
education moment the truth there are
seven words you can't say on television
even on cable I guess our basic cable I
guess it is so that actually that's
actually which is a choice that can be
made because technically and this is the
focus of the First Amendment case in
which your father's routine seven words
you can't say on television was the
focus yes for those of you who don't
know there's a very important First
Amendment case which involved this
routine which was played on the radio
and basically it said that the Supreme
Court came up with a new exception to
free speech if it's on broadcast
spectrum saying that the government has
greater control has a greater discretion
to regulate the content if it's if it's
something
that's broadcast over the broadcast
spectrum I won't go into the details as
to what that reasoning is but his
routine in terms of showing the
arbitrariness I think of yeah of this of
being able to regulate what's called
indecent speech would not be it was an
obscene so that was there was a new
category of speech that had been created
this indecent speech when he was he was
proud yeah well he's gonna ask about
that how do you feel about the fact that
his routine and and technically I guess
in some ways you could say if it proved
this point but in another way I mean the
free speech side loss yes how do you
feel about that that decision well you
know he always called it an accident of
history that he was involved in the case
he never felt like he I mean he wasn't
you know he didn't play the album WBAI
in New York played the album and it was
in the middle of afternoon the way my
disc my dad describes the moment is a
professional moralist was in a car with
his fourteen-year-old son when they
played the seven dirty words like this
fourteen-year-old son had never heard
these words and of course my dad's
argument was there are two buttons on a
radio the off switch
and the one that changes the station if
you don't like the speech choose some
different speech but this gentleman
decided to go and complain to the FCC
this thing ended up all the way in the
Supreme Court
my dad's biggest joy around this case
was that all nine justices had to listen
to the album to the piece that was
played the seven dirty words and that
and that the actual routine is in is in
the annals is in the is in the books of
the Supreme Court right now you can go
to your local law library and look up
the case and his routine is typed out
for everyone to see forever he took
great great pride in that but he always
did feel was an accident history so at
25 I went back to UCLA to get my bat my
bachelor's I became a communications
major and one of the classes we were
required to take was a First Amendment
class which was my favorite class loved
it almost became a First Amendment
lawyer like was very close then I
thought oh law school oh but my
professor I'm in a classroom of about a
hundred hundred and fifty you know maybe
a little bigger than this kind of a
sized classroom and my professor first
day of class was talking about the class
and how he loved teaching at his name's
Geoff Cowan around the Annenberg School
at USC and new Clinton a big First
Amendment guy and he says my favorite
thing about teaching this class is that
will study the pacifica versus FCC case
and I'll get to do George Carlin seven
dirty words for you now this has become
like a regular occurrence in my life
where I'm like somewhere innocently
minding my own business and my father
intrudes on my life and it was really
one of those moments where I saw so this
was in 80s about 90 and I really saw
like wow my dad's really had this
incredible impact on the culture at
large and the fun part was was getting
to go up to the professor afterwards and
going hi just want to let you know and
of course so the professor said to me oh
could your dad come would he come and do
the seven dirty words for us so I went
to my dad and I said so I'm taking this
class I'd explained the whole thing to
him and I said were studying the
Pacifica case and yeah professor we
really love for you to come and my dad
was so so cute and interesting his
reaction to that was oh no I couldn't do
that I don't know anything about the
case I mean it's just
an accident of history that it was me
and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and he's
going on and on about it and I just look
at him I'm like dad I don't think
they're asking you to know the law they
want you to come and be George Carlin
and say the seven dirty words but he was
just so darling about and so and I mean
that was really it really shows my
father's kind of humility my father had
a lot of humility about his place in the
culture and what he did and and you know
he really he really walked that walk big
time
and I don't even think it was until
probably just a few years before he died
that he even was acknowledging that he
was kind of an elder statesman in the
world of comedy in that you know he
would say things like well yeah when
they talk about comedy in the second
half of the 20th century they're gonna
have to mention me and I'm like really
dad you think so so I just I just I love
that about my dad I thought that's a
side of him I mean that's another reason
I wrote this book is that my father
everyone knows the version of my father
on stage and if you followed his career
over 40 some odd years you saw very
different versions of him on the stage
from the clean-cut guy who did the Ed
Sullivan and the early Carson shows
hippie-dippie weatherman Indian Sergeant
guy then boom all of a sudden he's
dropped acid and he's got a beard and
long hair and he's saying the seven
dirty words and then kind of in the 80s
its kind of floundering a little bit and
then late 80s early 90s he comes out
with jamming in New York and he's got a
whole nother level of political point of
view an outrage about the planet and
which came from him being a
broken-hearted idealist he he voted in
72 from McGovern and when McGovern lost
he never voted again he believed that
the system was broken and that's why he
used to tell say to people you know I
don't vote that way I have a right to
complain
I do vote by the way and I encourage you
all to vote but um but uh I forgot my
train of thought the evolution of my dad
and him growing and no I've no idea
where I was going
middle age well it's interesting that
your father was so humble about this but
every time I well at least I guess I
have to qualify it but every time I hear
comedians are at least the comedian's
that I really enjoy being interviewed
themselves and talking about their
influence your father is always up there
sure it's always him and Richard are the
two big ones
mr. Pryor Bill Cosby Lenny Bruce people
like Jon Stewart you Lewis Black yeah
Marv yeah all these folks always said to
me name your father as as the person who
was most influential and it was it your
father lived long enough to know that he
had been awarded the Mark Twain prize
for comedy by the Kennedy Center yeah
but unfortunately did not live long
enough to see or attend the ceremony
yeah yeah he was actually thrilled about
that you know he didn't really take a
lot of you know stock and awards and
things like that but when he heard he
got the Mark Twain he was he was happy
about that and of course I had been
secretly nominating him for years like
come on Mark Twain I mean come on people
George Carlin if there's not a Mark
Twain in our culture I mean you know and
and they picked some other people who I
get it it's a TV show and it's the
Kennedy Center and stuff like that but
you know and I'm a big fan of Billy
Crystal but really you're picking Billy
Crystal before George Carlin for the
Mark Twain prize you know so yeah he he
did he did know that and he he really
did appreciate it he loved it well when
when your father passed away and this is
the story about how we met I was a big
fan of George Carlin and and since he
was so associated with the First
Amendment both because of his case and a
number of other routines that he had he
had done we immediately posted on the
Thomas Jefferson web site sort of a
tribute to George Carlin unbeknownst to
me Kelly Carlin at
George Carlin's funeral there were two
organizations that were that suggested
that you might want to donate to these
organizations in lieu of flowers or
tributes one was the American Heart
Association which makes sense but the
other was the Thomas Jefferson Center
for the protection of free expression
which I had no idea that George Carlin
here's what's behind the scenes I mean
the idea that George Carlin had ever
heard of us and maybe he didn't but I
got a phone call and our administrative
assistant put it through and said Kelly
Carlin is on the phone and I didn't know
your name at the time and you my Pig
with phone and you introduced yourself
as George Carlin's daughter and I called
him because I wanted to let him know if
you get some donations in my dad's name
I want you to know why because I've
decided that you're the organization
that I'm gonna tell people to donate to
well apparently those Kelly your father
was a big believer in the underdog yeah
that's why I picked you guys are gonna
pick ACLU or Penn or all great
organizations but my dad was always
loved the underdog and I thought oh
here's a here's a nice little
organization that's you would need which
you told me also was like you looked it
up you're looking up researching
organizations and you bought the Thomas
Jefferson Center and because we just
posted it there was a photo of your dad
right there synchronicity and that was
too much I was like this is faith this
is faith
these people okay well once I realized
she wasn't some it wasn't a friend
putting me on you know that I picked for
Carlin daughter I was just so excited I
was so thrilled and so honored and then
typical of me sort of going too far and
putting my foot in my mouth I said gosh
I can't tell you what a great day this
is this is like two days two days after
her father had passed away and she's
grinning but then I knew it was really
known as George Carlin's daughter when I
went oh god I realized what I just said
and I hear this laughter on the other
end of the line that you appreciate it
and you said your father would
appreciated that at moment absolutely
absolutely but you obviously share up
for things you share your father's
commissioner humor and maybe in that
there lies the first event but your your
concern about censorship and people
government telling you what you can and
can't say yeah I mean I think that for
that that that class I took at UCLA
really taught me a great understanding
about what constitutional law in general
but the first I mean obviously watching
my father get arrested for saying the
seven dirty words and hearing Lenny
Bruce's story all the time your whole
life you're a person who's interested in
language and censorship but I think the
thing that is most important I mean it
is the First Amendment like that's
that's a little hint right there it's
not the sixth it's the first one and you
know when I when I got to learn that we
had to argue cases on both sides you
have to do in law school also we had to
argue both sides of the argument in
these First Amendment cases in this
class and I really learned that even
though I don't agree with your speech
I'll you know I will fight for the right
for you to parade down you know if it's
like the KKK in Skokie Illinois a famous
case you know it's like and here we are
in America in 2016 dealing with this
issue all over again and it's it's great
because I think it's a great teaching
moment for our country to talk about
speech and what is illegal speech and
legal speech and hate speech and
inciting violence and all sorts of
things so it's it's a really essential
essential conversation that we need to
be having as citizens and all citizens
should really understand their
constitution and and and all the
arguments involved in it I want to be
prescient of time here and I know we
have a clip of my dad and so I wanted to
set up the clip so this is a later in my
dad's life this is 2006 it's a few years
before he before he died and and then
we're gonna it'll lead right into this
clip that we're gonna play here Bob is
the name of my husband in November 2005
Bob and I flew to New York to see my dad
shoot his 30
HBO special life is worth losing I was
excited
my dad rarely let me glimpse his new
material before he shot it for HBO he
liked having me experience the material
in its full and polished form it was
always a thrill for me to sit in the
audience not knowing what was coming
this year I was especially looking
forward to seeing him we've both been
really busy and I hadn't when we hadn't
seen each other in about three months
after walking up the stairs backstage at
the Beacon Theater I caught my breath
and walked into his dressing room I saw
a short white haired man with his back
to me when he turned around it was my
dad I was stunned who took my father and
left this elderly man in his place my
dad's face was puffy he was 2 inches
shorter and he looked like he was
fighting to breathe what the hell I
noticed the last few times I talked with
him on the phone that he'd been a bit
scatterbrained very unlike my dad he'd
forgotten the name of his assistant once
and one day he didn't show up at a
breakfast we'd planned I thought at the
time it must be his age but seeing him
now backstage I knew something was
really wrong people don't age this
quickly I didn't say anything to him not
wanting to distract him from the task
ahead that night but as I walked to my
seat in the audience I worried if he'd
be able to make it through the show I
steeled myself for the worst
would he be okay would the audience
respond to how he looked might he even
collapse but when he took the stage that
night he came alive and all I could
think was if he could just stay there he
just might live forever
could you play the clip oh you're gonna
played here yeah this is dangerous they
put me in charge of this
Hania counted this week this will
demonstrate about George Carlin's love
of language that he passed on we got to
his mother and passed on to his daughter
I just want to read this one little bit
that comes right after this so a month
after this he really couldn't breathe
Christmas Eve morning Sally called Kelly
we're at cedars-sinai hospital George's
in the emergency room Bob and I raced
north on La Cienega Boulevard and found
Sally in the waiting room my dad's
girlfriend shaken up they've stabilized
him he's doing better about 20 minutes
later the ER doctor came out he's doing
much better than when he came in we gave
him some medicine lasix to help remove
some of the fluid from his lungs and
stabilize the heart failure - what heart
failure that's what had been going on
with him in New York
heart failure it is a condition they
could stabilize with medicine for a few
years but eventually only a heart
transplant would fix it permanently
after a while they let me see him as I
sat alone with him in the emergency room
he admitted to me that he'd had symptoms
for months and months and had ignored
them so that he could do his HBO special
I wanted to kill him but on the other
hand I got it it was a great show
as he lay there dozing i sat at the foot
of his bed with my hands on his feet
meditating and sending him as much life
force as I could I was doing my best to
uphold my shaman duties my dad called me
the shaman of the family I'd never felt
so peaceful in his presence before there
was a sweetness to it a week later they
released him from the hospital but now
he had a device implanted in his chest
it was a combination pacemaker heart
pump and defibrillator dad was oddly
proud of this device
because he bragged it's the exact same
device they implanted the chest of dick
chaney my dad died a few years later and
there's the ending of the book I don't
want to I don't want to give it away but
we had a great chance to heal and then
come together movie we were already
healed a lot of our pasts and stuff but
just an amazing ending happened for us
one that fits well with the beginning of
our story it feels almost like a
mythological legend in some ways and so
I feel very lucky and full of a lot of
gratitude that I got to heal with my
parents and we got to love each other
and laugh with each other through all of
the insanity and the roller coaster ride
of our lives and and I and I'm really
I'm so honored to be able to tell my
story to everyone and to share pieces of
my dad that people don't get otherwise I
think that was the point I wanted to
make earlier that part of the reason I
wanted to write this book was they they
see one version of my dad on stage that
guy but they don't know the husband and
the father and the man and the artist
the struggling artist and I it's just a
great privilege to be able to share that
part of my dad with the world so if you
guys have any questions we'd love to
take some questions I'll just say just
say one thing as the microphone is
making its round one of the things I
really enjoy about this book is is
learning a lot more about George Carlin
but even if you don't know anything
about George Carlin this is a wonderful
book to read for all of the other
aspects of your story but not just about
you but your mother is a fascinating
character yeah I wanted to get my mother
voice I like to talk about yeah wish we
had time to talk about the influence
that she had on you and and what she
heard her survivor story yeah
and it's it's it's always fun to learn
and see from a different perspective
somebody you think you know and then but
then you see it an entirely different
aspect of George Carlin's
life and character from reading this
book but also just this whole story of
this this unique you this unique story
your story yeah and it's just a very
very enlightening and also very
entertaining read so I I strongly call
it a page-turner I've hangers at the end
of each chapter
oh you must go to the next chapter now
well I'll just I'll just tell you what
Bill Maher says one hell of a ride Kelly
Carlin gives great insight into a man
who was a hero to many but a father to
one and it really is just a wonderful
wonderful reading so I strongly
encourage everybody to buy a copy if
they'd like this paperback is coming up
soon if you if you want to me but I've
always been a big influence in terms of
what people choose to buy and read but
but for me if you if you take the advice
of complete strangers that's probably
not a good idea but I highly do highly
recommend this book the question yes
what do you think your father would make
of today's political situation shocking
I got that question I get that question
ten times a day on Twitter well first of
all he'd love it
he'd absolutely loved it he loved here's
here's here's what I tell to people say
to people I say look this what my dad
said he said when you're born you get a
ticket to the Freak Show when you're
booked when you're born in America you
get a front-row seat
[Laughter]
and it feels like this day and age were
all in the VIP section he loved it he
loved it he died June 22nd 2008 he
didn't get to see Obama become president
he was excited though he was excited
about Hillary being you know being a
possibility of first female president
and then Obama started getting some
traction right around then and my dad
was excited when I went to Washington DC
to do the Mark Twain prize my husband
and I went to the Lincoln Memorial and
we were standing on the steps and the
presidential helicopter went over our
heads and it was Obama visiting the
White House for the first time and I
just I cried such tears for my father
because my father would have been my
father was a huge advocate having grown
up in Harlem and black culture and black
music if you know his earlier class
clown album stuff he talks about it a
lot occupation fool was a huge influence
on him and he was absolutely just you
know he would have been thrilled to have
seen that happen so but but nowadays
he'd be through oh the show the
spectacle of it all yeah so you know I
wish he was here to give us the more
specifics because he would have a unique
take on it that no one else has come up
with but I feel that we're in you know
as far as satirical comedy goes we're
still in really good hands there's a lot
of great satirical comics out there who
do political work and who are if you
haven't seen Samantha B's new
full-frontal show highly highly
recommended I think she's she's my
frontrunner right now I love her someone
else question right here I learned a new
expression this week post tramatic
thriving I wonder your experience
strength and hope about post traumatic
thrive oh that's so that's so beautiful
yay let's reframe that
yeah there's you know I think part of it
is you know we're kind of lucky with our
genetics we get some thriving genes some
resilience genes I come from really good
stock and there's something about love I
was really lucky to know that no matter
all the chaos in my life in my childhood
especially from age five to twelve I
knew I was loved deeply loved and
there's something about that early
childhood attachment theory they talked
about that is real so I knew I was
ultimately safe it took me a while to
ultimately figure that out as an adult I
mean I did have panic attack syndrome
and a agoraphobia for a few for ten
years but there is something about that
and at some point in all of our healing
process you need to move from the and
it's important to feel your pain to feel
your rage to feel the place of
victimhood that you are because you were
a child you have completely powerless
into okay now what that's a really
important shift in in a life and in a
healing and because it's ultimately it
is our life and we're adults and we have
to take responsibility for it and I had
to learn to take responsibility for my
anxiety and my depression and my life
and what I was gonna do with it and it
was terrifying and confusing but it's
the only thing that really saved my life
ultimately so thank you for that
question questions oh hi Kelly I'm Wendy
Edwards with News Radio 1070 WI a and
ninety eight nine FM and my question for
you is when it comes to dad isms that
especially in your teenage years made
you like roll your eyes and groan like
dad are you saying this to me again
what would that be that would probably
be the correcting of my my pronunciation
and stuff like that I mean my dad was
the coolest dad ever I mean hello when I
was in high school we shared weed
I know hard to roll your eyes if that
kind of a dad you know what I think my
parents were that first generation where
it was really confusing for parents
because they had partied a lot and they
didn't quite know how to and they didn't
buy into the just say no campaign and it
was actually before that that I was in
high school I was in high school in the
late 70s so they really couldn't put
their foot down and say oh do I wish
they had a little bit more yeah
I wish they'd created more limits for me
and more rules probably would have saved
me ten years of my life in my 20s but
once again they didn't and I had to
learn from that but yeah my dad was a
god to me you know and still a god to a
lot of people I've had to learn to take
him off the pedestal and realize he's
human but uh yeah I think for the most
part it was that kind of his you know
wanting to control my speech right here
so first of all thank you very much for
being here thank you very much for
writing this book and sharing insights
into someone that I know many of us in
here miss desperately yes in this evil
this week there was a blurb on this
particular session and there was a
comment about George's commitment to
truth yes in everything he said and one
of my earliest memories of George Carlin
was his description of a tomato which I
thought was just so dead-on truthful I
barely eat them still because in your
description can you talk about you know
that that aspect yes truth and honesty
beautiful I would love to so something
we actually didn't get a chance to talk
about here it's another big theme of my
book first of all the description of the
tomato that he's talking about if you
don't know it is my dad considered it a
food that was not finished
it would still undone had not finished
developing my other favorite food thing
was he never ate anything that he had to
break into its house to eat like a clam
I love that
I don't eat clams or oysters because of
that he was very influential in my life
one of the ironies of the karlon
household and one of the themes of this
book is truth-telling and my father was
the truth teller too quite a few
generations but growing up in an
alcoholic drug-addicted dysfunctional
household truth is a slippery slope and
it was confusing for me as a kid because
with dysfunction comes denial and denial
is about ignoring the truth the big
elephant in the room and so insane
things would go on in my life a very
famous story I tell as my father waking
me up one morning this was in the mid
70s and we just been to Hawaii on a
Hawaiian vacation my dad come into my
room and woke me up and said Kelly I
need you to wake up I think the Sun has
exploded and we have about seven minutes
to live and my father had been up for
about five days doing a lot of coke and
he was hallucinating and he was he was
screwed up and we went outside and it
was kind of hazy weird Sun and stuff but
anyway my point is that I couldn't go to
school on Monday and when I was asked
about Easter vacation how it was I
couldn't say well my dad's freaking out
on drugs and my mom and dad I must tried
to kill each other with knives and you
know I I couldn't speak the truth so I
had this very difficult relationship
with learning what my truth was and how
to express myself my emotions and
reality there wasn't a lot of reality
going on I was living a parallel life I
started living that's when I started
living a parallel life which is my my
persona and then my private life
that got me into a lot of trouble when I
got into an abusive relationship because
I didn't tell anyone about it for two
years in high school it got me into
trouble when I was doing way too much
cocaine and knew I needed help it got me
into trouble when I was at agoraphobia
and I couldn't get in my car and drive
around and couldn't explain to people
why I was no longer leaving my house so
it you know it's a very delicate thing
and one of the things that happened with
my dad and I was that um I in 99 had
written a one-woman show because I
wanted to talk about my mother and her
death and how it had transformed me and
part of it was I wanted to talk about my
childhood and how that was a part of
shaping me and how difficult that was
for my dad when I said I want to do this
show and he he part of it was difficult
because I talked about things in the
show that I'd never actually talked to
my dad about before feelings I had about
some things that had gone on and he said
to me like well why did I have to read
your script to find out about this and I
you know and I said well maybe maybe I
felt like I had to be on your stage for
you to finally hear me you know truth so
that's something my dad and I thought it
was a healing my dad and I had in our
life was we got to actually talk to each
other and learn to share the scary
things inside of us that all of us
humans go through and share our feelings
but yeah truth truth is interesting it
is relative at times how do you think
you just for your information sorry to
butt in back in and then questioning but
you've also done a one-woman show yeah
I'm doing a solo show now that I - were
a little bit yeah which which I was
fortunate to see in Los Angeles and it's
really a parallel to the scaffolding for
this this book's much more in depth but
yeah there's a lot there
I don't do how do you think your father
would feel about that show yeah because
that was written of course after his
passing yeah you know it started earlier
I think that um you know I think part of
my role in the family is to if he was
alive and I was doing it I mean for so I
don't know if that would be possible
because if a lot of what I say in the
times in the book where I talk about how
I back away from telling my story while
he's alive for different reasons
but I really see now that my role in the
world as a truth teller because my dad
did teach me to be a truth teller is to
speak my truth and to talk about our
shared humanity and that we're all
broken and we're all messed up and we're
all just trying to figure it out and
that's why I want to tell my story
because I want to I want people to feel
safe to tell their stories whether it's
to their loved ones or on a stage or
wherever it is we're only as sick as our
secrets as they say naa and so I think
in the end I think my father would be
very proud of me because I have figured
out what my role is as a truth teller
and that I'm and this is not and I mean
and there's nothing daddy dearest in
this book at all when this book first
came out so be we're like you know
trolls on the Internet and I'm like
really have you read the book do you
know anything about it there's so much
love in this book there's not a moment
of complaining or victimhood so and I
think my dad would get one thing I say
in the solo show is that you know when
people come to see my show or read my
book they always love my dad so much
more than they used to because now he's
a whole person to them and only once at
a speaking gig how did a guy come up to
me and say I gotta tell you I've lost
respect for your dad now that I know
that he you know he you know that he
couldn't function that well as a human
and stuff and I was like wow dude that
says a lot more about you than it does
well I think I think the cover photo
that you chose for the book just says so
much about your relationship I mean you
can just see this picture it's just my
dad even if you don't buy the book kind
of come up and look at this this
photograph next question thank you yes
coming back to your reminding us of what
the seven words are yeah you can't say I
was thinking I wonder how they're gonna
subtitle that if someone is running
subtitles as they watch the television
but then that led me to thinking about
what publications do where they will
take those seven letters seven words and
they will print the first letter xxx or
aspiration know what they're saying but
is more a First Amendment question than
anything else the question is what's the
point yeah and yeah what kind of trouble
with a publication a general purpose
publication get in for actually shocking
the world with the full spelling of
those seven words
well I'd actually if you were here a
pointed I have John Jeffries former dean
of the law school also a member of the
center's board of trustees professor of
all of the looks will answer that
question so I'm very nervous in
answering it myself because I probably
get it wrong but the fact is in a
publication that's probably a question
of choice by the publication they it
would be very difficult under First
Amendment law to get in any trouble for
particularly if they're talking about it
in this context but to use those words
in a publication or something like that
it that would not meet the definition of
obscenity the indecency provision only
applies to broadcasting this less
they're protecting your speech so it's
basically a an air glut the actual
content and it's a big part of the
definition is where it's being done and
in fact here's where I think I'm I think
I'm right John but of the words that we
said here when you see the Daily Show
with Jon Stewart and they bleep those
words out our cable television or
satellite television that's really a
question of choice the choice of the the
the people who are producing the show
it's not a requirement because those
shows aren't presented to you via the
broadcast spectrum I won't go too much
into the weeds as to why the government
has that that greater control but it's
an interesting development because I
don't think any of us today think about
oh this is this is a cable access
television show as opposed to NBC access
television right and but that it therein
lies the difference as to why you can
the government can have greater control
over broadcast spectrum and that that
indecency provision only as a matter of
law
if it is on the broadcast spectrum John
is that correct and what I always get is
when I read the word well you're reading
the word the word is being set in your
head so it's not like you're going wow
maybe it's spot so silly
well it's it's we were just talking
about this do you they're used to
there's a television show on recently a
few years ago Battlestar Galactica which
was a took place
you know he's human humanoid beings but
in another universe they the way they
got around this was they created their
own curse words and their own indecent
words and the word was fracking now just
imagine another word now imagine a word
that begins with F that many of us might
be offended by but just used liberally
oh I don't give a frak why don't you go
frak yourself I mean they just
completely because it was a different
culture that's great the other thing
interesting about your thing is in
Virginia Beach there's an ordinance
which i think is credibly
unconstitutional local ordinance but
that you can't curse in public there are
these and you think yeah yeah and it's
it's still on the books tested but on
street signs and Virginia there's the
exactly the kind of thing you see where
you see the little like asterisk and
pound sign for cuss words so only
they're all put up there and then
there's a red circle with a line through
it and it's posted I go walk down
Virginia Beach and in the streets and
you'll see those signs there and people
are fine for those next questions ask my
friend Cheryl glad you're here I'm
curious because I actually don't know
the answer is back in the day before
paparazzi is as big as it is today who
was your family unit ever know we were
so elated we were so lucky we never were
I think because of my dad wasn't part of
the pop culture we never we're the you
know the the sickest thing about tabloid
stuff is that the one time we showed up
there is when my mother
was dying of liver cancer and we were in
the National Enquirer for that and I
just like you've got to be kidding me
I was just horrific but no we're very
lucky very lucky that in my teenage
years there was nothing like that really
around yet as I was hanging out I went
to school in LA with all sorts of
celebrities kids and we were doing a lot
of illegal things a lot of drugs and
stuff and just crazy teenage stuff and
thank God we weren't being it's not like
the Kardashians or anything and I thank
God there was no Facebook but yeah we
were always very protected and the you
know really back in the day like when we
knew each Errol's a friend of mine from
Venice we lived there in the early early
70s together during that time what was
really dangerous was the cops I mean you
know that's was more dangerous in our
family than anything was feeling like my
dad could be arrested in any moment
because he usually was going to be but
yeah I'm really glad there wasn't thank
God
anyone else hi Kelly Cuba yesterday we
did a great podcast and I'm with the
Thomas Jefferson Center as well and
Kelly came on and discussed a lot of
things that you didn't hear today so if
you want to go listen to it it's the
muzzled podcast but one of the things
that I think fascinated me the most was
the response both of his fans after his
death to you and kind of disparate
responses as well as the response of the
comedy community which you had not
before been apart yeah so before my dad
died I was not I'd watch a little bit of
comedy it was my dad's job and my dad
was like did theater so we didn't go to
comedy clubs growing there were no
comedy clubs when I was growing up if it
wasn't a thing so I didn't know a lot of
comedians I think I knew one or two
maybe and when my dad died comedians
started calling me immediately that the
next day and I found myself you know
sitting on the floor of my bathroom
crying into the phone with Garry
Shandling one
morning and it was really an incredible
thing because the comedy family a lot of
comedians who you talked about some of
them who really my dad was like their
father great uncle of comedy and they
all said to me we're here for you
we know you're alone and we are your
family now and if you ever need anything
please pick up the phone and call us and
so that was an incredible feeling
because my dad you know was this huge he
was the son of my solar system and you
know here he was gone and then because
social media became a thing that summer
2008 was really when I got involved in
Facebook and it really became a thing
his fans found me and the first year and
a half or two I don't know what I would
have done without the fans because they
really lifted me up and they loved me
unconditionally and they took me in and
really and we shared we shared
everything about my dad I could have
conversations with them about them and
we could share his humor and his
material and his stuff and you know it
in some ways I had to eventually grow
out of that and and walk out of the
shadow of that a little bit but in order
for my sanity but but really I felt like
they it was like this beautiful web of
love and light that it caught me and
kept my head just above the water of
grief for a few years so that I didn't
completely disappear into it and it's
really an interesting thing about grief
as many of you know it's it's a it's a
very unique process but now that the
book is out which was came out last
September I feel like on some level that
I'm done being George Carlin's daughter
I mean I'm still AM
but that I'm actually able to now have
my own time of personal grief that I
don't have to be on display anymore and
even though I do events like this and do
my show a little bit that is a private
space for me now because there's this
there's the public thing here so
it's a fascinating but it fast I've been
watching my journey it's been very
fascinating so we have a few more
minutes Oh time we got a time from the
tea lady that the tea lady okay we're
good yeah we're gonna I'm gonna sign
some books if someone wants to buy some
books I'll sign them or whatever and
we'll meet and we'll take the proposals
and selfies yes before we cut off yes we
got please fill out an evaluation I'm
told to do that evaluation turn your
cellphone's back on but the other thing
I was going to say petition whatever
local theater paramount or something to
have to have the play version of this
book to sign up to bring bring this to
Charlottesville it's such an
entertaining production
[Applause]